we do have fabiana caruana after a draw
against peter fiddler fabia i just have
a couple of quick questions for you
starting with your mindset coming into
this game given that you were half a
point out of first
yeah i wanted to win um
i thought that
i could put pressure with white and and
i even had id an idea to play this in
this line i was trying to play it in
previous games in the tournament but i
didn't manage
um
[Music]
and i think he was kind of surprised so
i got a good good position um
i was surprised he went for
what was a very statically
um i mean a position where basically
he's just trying to hold
but he has of course the drawing margin
is very high i mean he can
um
instead of cd4
no no no
forward
after
after i castled
he can play like for gay a c4 there's
various
various moves uh
cd4 is is admitting that he's um trying
to
to simplify as much because of course
the obstacle bishops and the open
position makes it
sort of drawj but if i get a grip if i
get bishop d4 f3 rookie one then he
really suffers
maybe queen before it was bad maybe
queen queen b3 was a better move i was
actually regretting that i played queen
before and queen b3
avoids the bishop before stuff because
my bishop on e3 is defended so there's
always f3
um
this doesn't work out
because you play queen b4 and then you
play bishop to e4 and he decided to take
on b6 well i i thought a long time the
first thing is that okay f3 doesn't work
because of bishop f3
um
and rook fe1 which looks like it
prepares f3
he suddenly has queen h5
and then i'm in serious danger actually
because f3 rook f3 and
uh no not work fd1 um work f e1 okay one
sorry two pair of three because if i get
f3 i think i'm just
crushing it yeah yeah
but queen h5 so queen g4 is a threat
queen g6 is also a threat um and if f3
rook takes f3 and if i take i get mated
so this was unfortunate
um
and so i spend most of my time
trying to figure out
how to not play queen takes v6
and i thought mainly about queen d2
which is
not really the ideal move but it does
prepare f3 um
okay rook a3 and i
it's very very complicated and i
couldn't quite see how to proceed here
um
so i mean there's a lot of
a lot of messy lines uh
but i just didn't see my next move you
know i've i have f3 i have bishop d4
um
but he has like queen h5 he gets all
this incredible activity with the
sacrifices on f3 and rook d3 coming
and queen takes b6 i had a feeling it's
going to be a draw but i hope that
there might be some way to put pressure
in that game but i couldn't um
see the way
if we may interrupt first momentarily
looks like
dominguez has blundered
and maybe lost in this position he
played the move bishop to e6 and the
rook takes e4 bishop takes and rook to
f4 seems to be quite advantageous one
second we don't have you on there we go
if you could repeat the variation we
didn't have sorry uh
bishop e6 can be bit by takes takes and
rook to f4
and
uh this the threat on this bishop
obviously this doesn't do anything
because of this rook taking and there is
no perpet as your rook is in trouble you
can't touch this bishop so bishop to e6
it looks as though rook takes e4 bishop
takes and rook moves your bishop could
draw back and then he could shut
everything down with g6 black is up a
pawn this one doesn't look long for the
world either so looks like lanier may be
in big trouble that would shake up the
entire standings uh of course
let's get back to uh fabi finishing your
point no my game's not interesting let's
let's
so so your game your game ended in a in
a draw now uh you must be
not too thrilled with seeing the draw or
maybe you are happy seeing the draw
happen between maxima and wesley because
you're still only half a point out of
first
i kind of expected a draw in that game
so i i mean i'm i'm a bit disappointed i
couldn't
do more in this game couldn't put more
pressure on him i i felt like there
should have been a way to be more
accurate
um
but
you know i i like i don't think i miss
anything
um crushing you know it's not like i had
a winning position or anything i had a
bit of an advantage and i didn't make
the most of it
um and as for
what happened in maximus wesley i
i really don't see why
that affects me too much
i mean
uh
well you'd have to win tomorrow and hope
that
maxine draws right in order to tie for
first yeah i mean for me it was the most
important was to
was to win today
um it's a you know i'm playing richard
in the last round
um he's a very fighting player so that
makes all results possible i don't think
he's um
going to be searching for
a quick draw or anything i think he's
going to fight um
and that's also not a bad thing for me
potentially
so so we'll see
all right well good luck tomorrow thank
you thank you fabi